hey guys it's Justine and today we have
a brand new drone to unbox inside of
here is the new mavic 3 Pro let's open
it up this is a pre-release version so
that's why there's no art on the
packaging the one thing that I loved
about the previous version of the mavic
3 was it had this really cool carrying
case and it looks like they have one for
this too so
organized little case that we've got
here so we've got extra propellers we've
got the controller look at this with the
built-in LCD here's the drill oh my gosh
this is just what it just looks like a
little Transformer with this little
harness on I loved the mavic 3 like it's
definitely one of my favorites there's
obviously so many drones to pick from
but this is definitely
of way a higher end drone for all of
your droning needs and look at this it
has three freaking cameras can you
believe it three we've got the multiple
battery charging dock USBC cables and
extra batteries this case is great
absolutely love this so with the fly
more kit you obviously get the extra
batteries which makes a huge difference
when you're flying but it's incredible
the amount of time that we're able to
get on these drones now so you can get
up to 43 minutes of flight time on One
battery which is pretty impressive
what's in here
oh this is new check this out we've got
two USBC ports and we have the charging
adapter to plug in this also came with
all of the various plugs that you would
need for international travel so much
easier to charge my drone
internationally look at all these
options I actually really like that this
came
with this adapter adapter this is great
I can charge my batteries and the
controller at the same time so here's
our three cameras this thing looks like
a little honeycomb like something that a
b would just come in and deposit some
honey but this is honestly so cool
because being able to get various focal
lengths for one device is pretty awesome
like we don't have to switch any lenses
the one thing that I will be curious
about though is how the ND filters like
do we oh look at that that just pops
right off so we have our main camera
which is very similar to the mavic 3 but
it has now added 10 bit d-log M and you
could shoot 4K 120 which is pretty
impressive the second camera is going to
give you a 70 millimeter equivalent and
you can shoot up to 4K 60 and the third
camera will also shoot 4K 60 but with
166 millimeter equivalent which is about
a 7x Zoom it's pretty awesome that
you'll be able to get an optical zoom up
to that high before you could obviously
do a lot of digital Zoom but allowing
you to get three different shots right
here you're in just one drone is pretty
awesome and I cannot wait to take this
out much like the previous mavic 3
there's the three Pro and then there's
gonna be the three cine now the three
cine is also very interesting because
you can record apple prores on all three
lenses but on this one you can only
record prores on the main camera and on
the cine version you'll have up to one
terabyte of storage built into the Drone
which is very nice this does have the
omnidirectional sensing so you will be
able to have obstacle avoidance and you
can get up to 15 kilometers of video
transmission which is pretty far and
honestly when you fly you really should
always try to have a line of sight of
your drone so if you're trying to fly
this thing super far away and you can't
see it um be careful
made this little harness a little bit
smaller which I really like so when you
are out and about everything will just
be safe and secure right inside its
little cage it also brings us to the Pro
Controller I like the joysticks are also
separate and you can put them away
underneath that's nothing new that's
pretty much in all of their drone
controllers time to get this thing set
up and hop on a plane to go off on an
adventure
thank you
[Music]
I'm very excited I'm finally going to
get a chance to fly the new mavic 3 Pro
the problem is on the island they do not
allow drones to be flown on the property
unless you have a security person
accompanying you which actually I think
is kind of cool because this is such a
private place that if you do want to fly
one they allow you they just want to be
able to see what you're doing
yeah
yes
I am back from the Maldives I'm now
freezing in Pennsylvania but I had the
best time flying this drone
unfortunately I couldn't really take it
out and really explore the island as I
wasn't able to but I did fly it for a
few days and one of the things that I
love so much about the mavic 3 is just
how easy it is to fly it is so seamless
it is so smooth I had no issues
whatsoever I even flew it one day in
some very windy conditions and this
thing can handle its own another one of
the reasons why the last mavic 3 was one
of my favorites and now they basically
have just enhanced that drone to make it
even better obviously the selling point
of the new map mavic 3 Pro is the three
cameras so you can see here at my
parents house and I'm filming these
goats sheep I'm not really sure so this
is what it looks like in just the normal
lens and then we're gonna go and zoom
into 3x and you can see we're getting a
little bit closer and now we're zoomed
into 7x one thing I will caution you if
you've never flown with this zoomed in
perspective it really does kind of throw
off where you think the Drone is because
you are so zoomed in so you may lose
track of where your drone actually is in
the air so I do recommend being very
very very careful if you are flying
zoomed in and you've never done this
before and around here there are a lot
of trees but what I do like is I Can Fly
Above the tree line and I know that as
long as I'm not going down I'm not going
to hit any trees I didn't shoot a ton of
footage in raw I did shoot some just to
test it out but I loved the look of this
straight out of camera so a lot of the
stuff that I did film was just straight
out of the camera so it wouldn't
actually have to color correct but I do
love that this does give you the option
if you do want to go in and do a really
professional color grade this gives you
all of the flexibility to do so there is
an ND filter pack and here they are I
did end up using these a bunch in the
Maldives because it was so bright and so
Sunny that this is definitely something
that I highly recommend you get for any
of your drones or even if you're just
filming outside with any camera ND
filters are a must it's pretty cloudy
out right now and I actually have one on
this camera as well the battery life on
this thing it's just so freaking good it
was really uncomfortable because I was
flying obviously with a security guard
person watching me the entire time while
I was flying and he just kept being like
so how long does this stay up or like 40
plus minutes later I go I swear we're
almost done he's like but didn't that
beeping mean that you should bring it
home I go yeah yeah yeah we're gonna
bring it home very very shortly I mean
it just flies so long that it really
does allow you to get up there get some
great shots I was even doing a
hyperlapse after I had been filming
doing for like 20 minutes it's just so
amazing that we're in a place now where
drones do have the ability to be up in
the air for over 40 minutes that's so
impressive I also took a few photos
which is something that I always forget
about on my drones because I'm always
focusing on video so obviously here are
a few of the photos that I took I am
washing back this footage and missing
the Maldives already what a beautiful
magical place I had such a great time
this also gives you the ability to
detect a manned aircraft so any small
planes larger planes helicopters all
that stuff will actually show up on the
radar which is such a huge help because
the one morning I was flying they had a
bunch of inbound seaplanes coming in so
anytime there was one nearby I would
automatically get an alert I would know
to bring this closer to me or I could
determine where that plane was where I
could be at a safe distance from it I'm
such a huge fan of that and it was
really great to kind of see that in
action because a lot of times when I'm
flying in the middle of nowhere I'm
usually not in any other flight pattern
so the fact that I was able to see that
firsthand was pretty cool well thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
guys enjoyed this quick look at the
mavic 3 Pro I'll put a link in the
description if you want to get more
information or to purchase I freaking
love this thing this will definitely be
coming with me on all of my next travel
Adventures so I look forward to taking
this out and flying with it more and
with that my friends I will see you guys
in the next video leave me some comments
below and let me know what your favorite
travel destination is or a dream travel
destination I would love to hear about
it bye
foreign
[Music]